let's get to your fifth take away which
is the lions dan campbell the detroit
lions we've been watching them all year
round and we're always saying they are
playing good teams tough and now you're
starting to see them win they just beat
arizona
man this is week 15. we're in week 15
and we're still seeing the lions play
hard to me that just shows how much
respect they have for dan campbell they
know if you know dan campbell as a
player you knew that he was a tough guy
he fought he clawed you know all the
biting of the ankles but it just shows
me that they have a level of respect for
this guy in order for them to take that
next step they're going to have to
upgrade their roster and what does that
mean they're going to have to get free
agents to come to detroit how do you get
free agents to come to detroit you don't
if you got a great quarterback which
they don't have you got to overpay guys
so if it's me i'm going to get guys that
can make a difference like a chris
godwin you might have to overpay for him
to go you know come to the team or you
know a safety like marcus williams if
the saints don't decide to pay him you
got to bring impact players in here into
detroit surround them with you know just
surround these impact players
you know with the talent that you
already have and see what happens but
nobody wants to come to detroit if
you're not going to overpay and that's
what they're going to have to do they
have to get some more talent and overpay
there's some cornerstone pieces when you
watch this team watch that arizona game
they have good tackle play really good
tackle play between taylor decker and
penne seoul and that takes you a long
way now you just need average guys in
the interior of that offensive line
deandre swift he's a young running back
that i think has star potential then you
look at amanra st brown who i went to
notre dame with his brother equineby
saint brown and he's the better version
he went to usc he became a fourth-round
pick but he's their leading receiver all
year long and tj hawkinson the tight end
who's gonna miss the rest of this season
but when he comes back he's a darn good
tight end so that's some pieces if you
add an extra receiver like you're
talking about could be something there
you probably have to add you're gonna
have to add two more you're probably
gonna have to add two more receivers a
little bit more depth at the tight end
position and more depth at the running
back position but where your focus needs
to be is on the defensive line getting
those pass rushers and making sure you
have corners i know they have the young
corner out there number 24 i forget how
to say his name
forgive me um but he's a good young
player i think he had an interception um
this past sunday but they're gonna have
to get like a stud free safety in there
a guy that can really come in and
control you know the defense so just add
a few more pieces and um we'll see a few
more victories next year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports